grass dipping no it's not some new
fangled way to get high it's actually a
clever exploit that had to be banned
from iRacing fittingly named grass
dipping refers to when a player drives
over grass to cool their tires like re
life racing things like tire wear matter
so cooling them as you drive will
actually help them to last longer grass
dipping was thought to gain Racers about
half a second per lap depending on the
track and it got so bad that at the
24-hour Spa race in 2022 nearly every
car was doing it issues for them out
there but everybody the chemel straight
for the second time in this race as a
result of this broken and boring tactic
iRacing was forced to ban it completely
however it wasn't the last we'd see of
it in a bizarre case of Life imitating
art grass dipping was used in an actual
professional real life race oh I know
what he's doing this is what he's doing
this is this is a an online racer trick
it's frowned upon in online racing